okay you guys so let's see how well my
kids know me let's see if they can tell
the difference between their mama
and their Auntie Tia Mowry puts her kids
to the test with the ultimate challenge
name that twin mommy or Auntie I'm a
strong believer that children learn
through observation on Wednesday Tia
shared this clip to tick tock pulling up
a promotional photo from her 90s sitcom
Sister Sister which starred Tia and her
twin sister Tamara
Cree so we'd see sister sister on there
okay you said who's Mommy
no
that is Auntie Tamara I cannot believe
you got it wrong
well you didn't get it right this time
what made you think that that was Mommy
because
small mall right there I don't have a
mole your Auntie has a mole okay so
Tia's 11 year old son Cree didn't
exactly nail the assignment you would
say that I'm like the coolest mom right
but what about her five-year-old
daughter Cairo that's just Kyra which
one is mommy go point to it
funny who's Mommy
yeah
[Music]
Tia shares cree and Cairo with her ex
Corey hardrict family is so important to
me the two finalize their divorce in
April after 14 years of marriage I have
to be honest with you so overwhelmed by
all of the support and the love that I
have received and I'm just so grateful
of the community and just the fans that
I have and the women the DMS that I have
gotten from so many women that are going
through the same thing and just saying
how they admire my courage and my
strength it I mean it has just been I
feel so blessed and last month Tia
showed off a new shorter do writing in
the caption there's something so
Bittersweet about a nice chop it feels
like a release of old memories both good
and bad but also an exciting start to a
new era I'm loving it so what's next for
Tia here's what she told E.T what does
this next chapter of life look like for
you
authenticity I think authenticity it
it's very magical when you are living in
your truth and your honesty I feel like
amazing wonderful things happen and so I
just want to encourage you know all the
women out there to live in their truth
and to live in their authenticity and we
got you you know what I mean we're all
in this together it's about a community
and supporting each other and
encouraging each other and inspiring
each other and I mean there's so many
great things that are happening in my
life and I just feel so grateful and
blessed